ravenous fans risking their lives for
radioactive Church keys and eerily
similar government cover-ups check your
radiation levels because this is the
unsold truth of HBO's Chernobyl
despite the fact that the show's
producers strived for HBO's Chernobyl to
be as historically and culturally
accurate as they could possibly make it
it's very common for filmmakers and
showrunners to take liberties with the
truth for the sake of the narrative and
this production was no exception to his
credits Craig Mason the Creator and sole
writer of the series felt the need to be
forthcoming about the Liberties taken
with the facts of the real events
depicted after all a major theme of the
show focuses on how costly certain lies
ended up being the research I did for
this production was horrible possibly
the most gruesome way to die is by
severe radiation poisoning in an effort
to help bridge the gap between Hollywood
and reality Mason created the Chernobyl
podcast airing concurrently with the
show where he and co-host Peter Sagal of
NPR's wait wait don't tell me discussed
which elements of Chernobyl were based
in reality and what had been changed for
the storyline Mason is no stranger to
the world of podcasts since 2011 his
Cohen said the screenwriting series
script notes with a fellow screenwriter
John August the script notes podcast is
devoted to everything that would
interest any screenwriter whether
they're a novice or a professional a
month after the series finale the
Chernobyl podcast produced a bonus
episode with actor Jared Harris who
talked about his experience portraying
Valerie legosov and the responsor show
received throughout the world Chernobyl
series Creator Craig Mason visited the
abandoned Chernobyl town in pripyard as
part of his research for the acclaimed
miniseries he did this to get a sense of
the size of the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant which helped him understand how
the workers in the control room would
have responded to the explosion in
reactor number four Mason describes his
experience as something of a religious
experience even though he himself is not
very religious in the month after the
show premiered Reuters reported that
tourism companies reported a 40 rise in
bookings to the Chernobyl exclusion Zone
the Ukrainian government led by
president fellow demia zelinski
officially announced such a noble would
become an official tourist site after a
visit to the exclusion Zone zelinski
said we must give this territory of
Ukraine a new life until now Chernobyl
was a negative part of Ukraine's brand
it's time to change it even though the
government's tourism campaign may have
helped Ukraine's economy officials and
scientific experts have expressed their
doubts about the growing number of
visitors pouring into the abandoned city
as it remains among the most
radiologically contaminated locations on
Earth more than three decades after the
accident to fuel the skepticism
according to the Washington Post there
have been reports of bad behavior on
behalf of the tourists particularly
because they would ignore health and
safety protocols by entering dangerous
spots to take selfies rummaging through
abandoned buildings and stealing objects
left behind a souvenirs Jared Harris has
repeatedly admitted that three-time
Academy Award winner Daniel Day Lewis
was apparently the first choice to
portray Soviet nuclear scientists for
Larry lagosov and HBO's Chernobyl
referring to Daniel Day Lewis's
announcement that he was retiring from
acting in 2017 after finishing
production on Paul Thomas Anderson's
movie Phantom thread Harris told the
guardian he was supposed to do the part
in Chernobyl thank God he retired it
wouldn't be the first time that Day
Lewis was the first choice for a role
that eventually went to Harris revealed
that Day Lewis was also initially
offered the role of arch nemesis
Professor Moriarty in guy Richie's
Sherlock Holmes a game of shadows which
was rumored to be circling around Sean
Penn and Brad Pitt before Harris was
hired a week before the film started
shooting Paris has quipped about this
often going on to say everything gets
offered to him first everything Day
Lewis and Harris previously collaborated
on Steven Spielberg's acclaims 2012
biographical drama Lincoln in which
state Lewis portrayed the titular
historical United States president and
Harris portrayed Lieutenant General
Ulysses S Grant Day Lewis even made it
into Harris's acceptance speech is bafta
win as best leading actor for Chernobyl
where Harris playfully jabbed at Day
Lewis with the following remark don't
stay away too long you know I miss
seeing you up there
in the show ulana comyuk is a nuclear
physicist who joins Valerie legosoft and
Boris sherbina in their investigation
into the Chernobyl disaster after
detecting the radiation in Belarus
nearly 250 miles from the site of the
nuclear disaster in the show's
penultimate episode
ulana steps sentenced a voice of reason
and accountability when lagosath must
decide between disclosing the truth
about the Soviet Union's neglect with
the rbmk reactors that cause the
Chernobyl accident or playing it safe
and remaining on good terms with the
government unlike lagosov and Shabina
who played a significant role in
mitigating the disaster in real life the
character of Lana comyuk isn't based on
any specific real-life figure she's a
composite character made to mirror the
real world women who were a vital part
of the medical and scientific scene in
the Soviet Union series Creator Craig
Mason noted in the Chernobyl podcast
that's although the Soviet Union had a
few women in political and governmental
roles in the fields of science and
medicine the silver yets were actually
very Progressive in that regard I'm a
nuclear physicist
before you were deputy secretary you
worked in a shoe factory
if you was off to Noble will notice that
even though the show takes place in
Soviet Ukraine none of the characters
speak Ukrainian or Russian or even
English for the Russian accent as they
would in most English language movies
and TV shows set in a non-english
speaking region while it may seem like
an oversight the dialects and accents of
the show's characters were a conscious
decision for the producers the director
of Chernobyl Johann rank revealed in
bafta's the making of Chernobyl that
there were discussions about producing
the show in Russian and Ukrainian but
that idea was ruled out for the Global
Production series Creator Craig Mason
explained on the show's Companion
podcast that Russian accents and English
media tended to appear quote comical
which would obviously impair the serious
tone of the disaster tragedy show The
Producers considered having actors to
vague Eastern European accents that
weren't as strong as full-blown Russian
accents but would be noticeable however
they found that actors would focus on
the accents rather than being true to
the emotions of their characters after
which The Producers to decided to scrap
the idea completely according to
Cosmopolitan they decided to keep the
show's casting within the confines of
Europe by avoiding casting American
actors as they realize that much like
the Russian accents American actors
would be too distracting for the viewers
to focus on the drama of the show
when a TV show is as popular as
Chernobyl was Network Executives often
find it tempting to Fast Track the
release of a second season and plan a
full franchise HBO's Chernobyl however
was always planned to be a limited
series and a one-time television event
the story was written to conclude in
five episodes a series Creator Craig
Mason made clear in interviews promoting
the show and on the show's official
podcast however when Aspire decided
about the scope for a second season
Mason pointed out the possibility of
focusing on another crisis similar to
Chernobyl such as the Bhopal gas
disaster or the Fukushima nuclear
disaster these stories which share a
common theme of fatal tragic incidents
course and covered up as a result of
human ignorance and arrogance would
undoubtedly be formidable successes to
the story of Chernobyl and to make for
an intriguing Anthology series for those
who are curious the Bhopal gas disaster
was an industrial accident that occurred
in 1984 when a highly deadly gas spilled
from a pesticide facility in Bhopal
India and spread to nearby towns
according to the Atlantic over 500 000
people were exposed to the gas making
the chemical disaster one of the worst
in world history the 2011 Fukushima
nuclear disaster was a result of a
nuclear accident at a power station in
Okuma Japan which was brought on by the
worst earthquake ever registered in that
country according to the international
business times the disaster was given a
level 7 classification on the
international nuclear event scale making
it the only other event to get such a
designation other than Chernobyl
HBO's Chernobyl received positive
reviews from Russian audiences and
critics citing that the show did a
better job of portraying the Chernobyl
disaster and its Soviet setting than any
Russian Film or television program
however the praise didn't prevent
accusations from state-run television
and Russian tabloids they claimed that
the show had distorted the truth by
portraying Soviet era leaders in a
negative light in terms of radiation
plant director bukhanov reports no more
than 3.6 ronkin I'm told it's the
equivalent of a chest x-ray it was
reported that as a response to the HBO
show Russian NTV which is known to be
Pro Kremlin was set to air its own
retelling of the Chernobyl disaster a
show centers on a Russian
counter-intelligence agent assigned to
track a CIA operative who's been
dispatched to pripyards to gather
intelligence on the Chernobyl power
plant in an interview with the Russian
tabloid comsamol skya pravder the
director of ntv's Chernobyl Alexi
muradov cited the theory that Americans
that infiltrated the Chernobyl nuclear
power plant going on to assert this
claim had never been denied by
historians according to the BBC an
apparent trailer for The NTV show was
uploaded to YouTube but was later
removed after backlash
amidst the political and bureaucratic
drama taking place throughout the show
Ludmila ignatanko storyline in Chernobyl
provides a civilian perspective on the
disaster as well as its consequences on
innocent Soviet citizens who are unaware
of the true dangers of the radiation
stemming from the explosion much like
most of the show's characters lewd Miele
and her husband vasili ignatanko were
real people a series crater Craig Mason
revealed on the show's Companion podcast
ludmila's story was one among many other
civilian accounts and testimonies of the
disaster featured in The Book voices
from Chernobyl in an interview with BBC
Russia following the success of the show
the real-life lewd Miller broke her
silence and claimed that she was never
approached for permission by the show's
producers to use her name or her story
she revealed that the release of HBO's
Chernobyl resulted in journalists
invading her privacy to get an interview
with her she also faced accusations from
several people saying that she had
harmed her then unborn child referring
to the scenes in the show when the
pregnant Ludmila had close contact with
her radioactively infected husband
despite warnings from doctors HBO and
Skye refuted her allegations say Nath
ignatenko and the production crew had
multiple discussions and that she had
been given the opportunity to offer
feedback drawing the writing process
they added that Ludmila never indicated
during the process that she did not want
her and her husband's story to be
featured on the show
according to the New York Times at the
onset of the kobit 19 pandemic Chinese
citizens noticed the similarities
between the Soviet response to the
Chernobyl disaster and the Chinese
government's initial handling of the
coronavirus outbreak in particular they
noted the Communist government's
incompetence when handling the crises
and the suppression of information
surrounding them no one leaves
and cut the phone lines
contain the spread of misinformation in
both cases the dangers were seemingly
invisible radioactive contamination and
an Airborne respiratory virus in the
case of Chernobyl it was only after
countries neighboring the Soviet Union
began detecting radiation that Soviet
leadership admitted there was a problem
similarly Chinese authorities only
reported the first cases of the
coronavirus and it spread outside of
Wuhan days after Thailand and Japan
reported cases of the infection
according to quartz the Chinese
government's deleted articles and
comments about the virus and people were
detained for quote spreading rumors
after posting about the virus on social
media as a result people took to the
Chernobyl page on Chinese film review
website dobahn to channel their
frustrations over the government's
handling of the virus users posted
quotes from the show and pointed out the
parallels between the show's story and
current events the Chernobyl page on
dobon eventually amassed over 200 000
ratings
foreign